the Estonian police in a few months ago
I think tried out on a particular piece
of roads an alternative way of
penalizing people who are speeding in
most countries when you get caught
speeding you get a ticket and in some
situations the fine can be quite
extensive
depending on how by how much you exceed
the speed limits but here in Finland
they come they came up with a different
idea and so they stopped people speeding
and they gave him a choice between
paying and I think for a sort of an
average excessive speed the fight would
be something like fallen euro so just
like a good three and fifty pounds or
they could wait for an hour just stay
there for an hour and then they could be
they could go get didn't have to pay
anything but they just had to wait by
the roadside for an hour about half of
the the people they stopped opted to
wait about half didn't so you can
imagine from that how much these people
value their time
I'm joined by Koontz Mets who I've been
fighting to pronounce that name but I
think I've managed to nail it welcome to
the show
thanks very much sure Chris you did it
proud I think I've heard numerous
strange mispronunciations
mispronunciations of my name all the way
from a keen to go into Cohn and anything
in between so yeah I think you were you
passed with flying colors fantastic or
you've got over the first hurdle and to
the listeners at home I'm starting to
calm down a little bit now you might not
know Kuhn but I was away in Bali and
while I was away it meant I couldn't
record and you do not know true fear
until you have a twice-a-week podcast
publishing schedule and no podcasts left
to publish and that is that is where
I've been over the last couple of weeks
but very fortunately for the people that
are listening I have this episode with
yourself which I'm sure is going to be
fantastic behavioral economics and all
sorts of decision-making Theory that
we're going to go into which I can't
wait to do also coming up Navarre rava
can't bro the caramel rava can't talking
about love yourself like your life
depends on it his brand-new book and a
bunch of other people that are really
really interesting over the next couple
of weeks but today we're gonna get to
talk about some behavioral economics and
some classical working strategies for
organizations human behavior
decision-making and motivation that's
right that's the kind of stuff I do yes
so what have you been thinking about
recently we've got the world is our
oyster the world of whatever you've been
working on is our oyster okay well one
of the things one of the themes I've
been thinking of recently is as time as
you as you may know it cannot be is
about scarce resources is about allocate
it's about allocating scarce resources
is about weighing up costs and benefits
and this is in the economy as we know it
is usually is to do with money or with
some kind of equivalent of money some
resources that you need to manage
but of course another very important
scarce resource we all experience is
time we get at every midnight we get 24
hours to put the next the next day so to
speak and once that's gone it's gone and
of course then there is another 24 hours
but we can just like we can spend a
pound or a euro or a dollar or any other
currency only once so we can only spend
a minute or an hour or a second
once and we if we spend it on one thing
we can't spend it on another and so are
a general use of time follows similar
patterns to the way we use money in the
sense that we we are confronted with the
fact that we don't have unlimited
amounts of it and so we need to be
careful in how we use it up and I think
that that is a fascinating topic for me
because in many particularly also
behavioral economics experiments and
economics experiments you get people in
a lab you give them some tokens you give
them a little bit of money sometimes you
see people go to developing countries to
India for instance where amounts in
dollar go much further so you can really
intervene in people's lives on the scale
of magnitude that is like comparable to
a month's wages for instance and still
be affordable for research but the
problem is with whatever experiments you
do with with tokens or money is that
it's usually in much smaller quantities
and really impacts on us in real life so
my thinking is that if we look more at
how we could reuse time where we all
have the same amount of time whether
you're rich whether you're poor you get
24 hours a day and it's not because
you're rich you get 36 hours a day we
all have exactly the same amount of time
and I think how we would respond to
having to weigh up gaining or losing
time might reveal things or clarify
things that perhaps are unclear or
ambiguous when you work with you give
people 10 pounds or 10 dollars then you
make them that's all
something or you make them pay for
something it it doesn't work the same
way I think and I think there is some
some mileage to be had out of using time
in in research on economics and on be
able to cannot make some human behavior
but time and money are intrinsically
linked aren't they they are as you know
the the old adage goes that time is
money but is it really that equivalent
is time really always money and I think
if you think about it not every minute
is has the same worth to you and to me
or to anybody else and if you if you are
in the middle of something that's really
important then your time will be much
more valuable than if you're just lazing
about on the city watching The Simpsons
and so I think you see it as well in in
overtime for instance people demand to
be paid more when they go over a certain
limits in terms of working for for an
employee or for an employer for a boss
so the the concept itself of being paid
50% more on double time for overtime
people are being paid more for working
in the weekend reflects immediately that
a time doesn't have a intrinsic stable
unique value and I think that in itself
is a is an interesting an important
observation that affects the way we
behave and we handle and we manage our
time absolutely there's a short blog
post I remember reading quite a while
ago that was talking about how as a
child you'd happily give up your day for
a dollar and there's an old man you'd
happily give up your fortune for a
minute yes very true and I think it's
quite kind of extreme as a child of
course you have no idea of the that the
finiteness of life you're 5 years old 8
years old remember when when school
broke up at the end of the spring
earlier summer
you had Belgium we we had two full
months of holiday of July and August
well the 1st of July is like you can't
even
see as far as the sounds like an
unlimited amount of holiday obviously by
the time mid-august came and then
easygoing buying out I know new books
and pencils and everything else law
school starting again so you get a sense
of time but yes you have no idea of the
finiteness whereas if you're an old
person then yes your your counting down
and you know well um maybe I mean my dad
is 92 a testament to some good genetics
that you've got that well I hope I
inherited his I didn't inherit his his
hair the genes and it says he's quite
bald and it's a fantastic head of hair
yeah it's it's a good good bargain but
but yeah he's 92 is still in good health
but of course he knows I isn't likely to
live another 20 years or maybe in other
10 years or maybe five years so you're
really looking at time in a very
different way that said it's interesting
that we we sort of go good and this
particular rabbit hole he lives on his
own and he hasn't got much to do most of
his friends and his his relatives except
for his children's on but his sort of
siblings and peers and although they've
all died so there's very few people left
of his generation and so he's he lost
purpose a little bit and so he's got
lots of time and doesn't really quite
know what to do with it
he loves gardening and all that but it
being winter and it's not a good time to
spend too much time in the garden so he
struggles to fill his days with with
something so I think if you look at time
as something that you would utilize in
terms of willingness to pay or
willingness to accept he would be
willing to pay for something to do
rather than having to be paid to do to
something and in a sense but yes I think
these are all examples of how we we look
at time with different different eyes
depending on how old we are
depending on what what day in a week it
is depending on what time of day it is
depending whether and holiday or not all
of them matters and makes us look at
time differently same at work as well at
work basically what we do we
we give our employer an out-of-time and
we get money in return and somehow we we
tend to view that time as sunk we've
sold it so it's now our employers
innocence so we are less concerned with
wasting our time and we certainly less
concern with wasting other people's time
I I did exercise once with the client of
mine where we had a workshop with about
50 people or so joining and one of the
things we had to look at was sort of
budgets and how much money was being
spent and I made them do the exercise if
what's this workshop costing and I even
revealed my feet so they could take that
into account and then they looked ok
well the higher of the venue and the
meal and this enough what they didn't
take into account at first was their own
time when I got fifty people earning
what between say sixty thousand and nine
and twenty thousand euros a year when
you get these that amount of people
together for two days that is a huge
amount of money or time equivalent of
money that you divert into something so
but we don't really think about it in
those terms we don't we think the time
we've were at work so now it's work time
we don't worry
worry about what we do with our time
whether we are using it well whether
you're using other people's time well
that's why you get so many complaints
about meetings being a waste of time and
wall-to-wall meetings and all day and
looking back and say well I have no idea
what I've done today but it's not very
much yeah I suppose so I think that
really is a fascinating topic that is
why think under studied and under and
the researched I've had a couple of
conversations the listeners may be
familiar with Laura van der Cam's
episode who is a time management expert
that was more from the productivity side
NER al as well also to do with task
prioritization you know as a sympathy
card that I'll throw out to some of the
people that will be listening many of
whom will be knowledge workers
I sympathize wholeheartedly with the
fact that your days are messy and you
haven't got a clue what you did with
them and when you look back at your day
and you think how did I spend my time
you know we even use we even use that
language linguistically we're talking
about it like it's money how did I spend
my time yesterday this allocated number
of units of temporal tokens how did I
decide to spend my time today and you
know I I feel for you because it is as
you say you've got I went into a meeting
then I sat down I had a coffee I did at
this that you know and it just fritters
away but yeah you you bring up in a
couple of your recent blog posts talking
about opportunity cost and obviously how
that relates to what I tell you what why
don't you why don't you explain to the
listen to what opportunity cost is do ya
opportunity cost is really is what you
what you do not do what you cannot do
when you do something else so to give a
simple example take a taxi driver you
take a taxi somewhere and you ask the
guy to wait for 20 minutes
and then because you're going to do
something and then you come out again
and you still on the taxi to be there
waiting for you to take you back home or
something so he is not going to say is
it's not going to do that for free to
the taxi driver the 20 minutes he's
standing there is 20 minutes he could
not be carrying somebody else another
paying customer so he's going to have to
charge you enough to compensate that and
that is the opportunity cost so he the
cost to him is not sitting there because
he could be looking at his Facebook
accounts or reading a paper or just look
out the window or you having asleep but
that's neither here nor there it could
be working as well and that's how we
will measure the cost of sitting there
for 20 minutes so that is what
opportunity cost is and that applies to
time as well as to to money of course it
also applies to money if you spend money
on a meal then that money is you cannot
use that money for something else so
there is an opportunity cost expressed
in what else you could buy with the
money that you spend on going out for a
meal let's try and dig down into the
nuance of the difference between
opportunity costs for money
for time because I think this is really
fascinating you can't not spend time is
that a fair statement to make yeah yes
absolutely not spend money yes
absolutely you can still you can say I'm
not gonna spend it I keep it for
something else you can't do that with
time or not not easy at least in the
same way you can't bank time maybe if
you if you play television quizzes then
sometimes a good bank you can bank money
in time but you haven't practiced yes
time at the second the last second the
second are just gone it's gone
we cannot reuse this at all of course
you can say I'm going to bring certain
activities forwards and do them now and
that is a good way of managing time over
a longer period of time as it were when
you say well the for instance what
people do when they travel they they do
something useful well while they're
traveling or while they're waiting and
so they can make time that would
otherwise be wasted as in time spent
without anything tangible anything
meaningful getting gotten in return you
can change that you can say well I may
be waiting for the plane maybe thirty
minutes delayed but actually I can start
writing my report and so you actually
make good use of your time but it
requires an degree of awareness and
deliberation to do that and we are not
we don't always do that and also we are
worse on the other in the other hand on
the other hand as well we we waste time
as well we we are not always consciously
using our time in the best possible way
I want to get you to elaborate on
awareness and deliberation in a second
but I'm thinking as you're talking
through that I'm hoping that some of the
people that are listening might be in a
situation like that there might be in
this sort of little pending waiting room
of Hell in between one thing that they
got to do and another thing they've got
to do and this thing would have sucked
and maybe me and you Chris and Kona
making this this afternoon or this
little waiting thing a little bit easier
maybe we were in their ears right now
we've got the headphones in listening
away perhaps that's the way that they're
doing it so if that is the case I hope
that we are
hope that we're making you your day a
little bit better but yeah let's let's
talk about um what was it decent
deliberation and awareness awareness
awareness awareness in the liberation
yes I think it's there the parallels
with money still go a long way here as
well I think we often spend money little
impulsively we don't really I mean we
are not what what economists used to
call and some still do homework
economicus the sort of rationale it's
maximizing self-interest its individual
so in other words if you spend a tenner
on some gadget or or assembler and a
drink or something you're not
considering what what else could i spend
this than rod can I just bring to mind
everything else I could possibly spend
this tenner on and and then sort of rank
them and say well the very best way I
can spend this is this not the sandwich
in this drink so I'm not gonna buy this
all by simply cheaper we don't do that
we sometimes spend money totally
impulsively but we also have some preset
limits we think are well for a tenner
I'm not going to spend half an hour
conjugating about where else could I
spend this even better on than here but
we we don't always weigh up the
opportunity cost of spending money and
if you go on holiday it means you can't
buy a new car for instance that's the
kind of thing that some people are aware
of and other people are not aware of and
so the same applies to to time in a
sense if you to give you an example from
when I was little I was maybe 12 13
years old and this is the time when
self-service petrol stations started
popping up before that it was all full
service so you drove up and a guy in a
uniform came along and sort of opened
your filler flap and fill the fill up
your tank with petrol and then you can
start doing it yourself
and these petrol stations gave a
discount and of course some gave a
little discount others gave a big
discount and I remember my dad we we
hadn't had a car
for a long time we we went we do have
like 20 minutes to get some discount of
one franc a liter or something not
particularly and I realize even then
that there was no calculation being done
so there was no whereas of how much time
let alone the distance driven but how
much time are we spending to drive about
10 miles to 15 miles to get petals of
this just a little bit cheaper and I
think we we often do not think about
that and we think about it even less
when it's about time we we don't really
think about how much time something
takes we we think we need to go to a
meeting that meeting is like two hours
drive away so we would just say well
there's some traveling time we that's
just part of the equation
we don't especially because time is not
even as tangible as money there is
salience time is not salient in the same
way you just take it as a given that
okay I'll have to drive for two and a
half hours and get there when we're
stuck in traffic
we don't really calculate how much time
we waste stuck in traffic I mean I I try
to avoid driving as much as I can but
when when occasionally I have to take
the car and have to drive during rush
hour and I see these people who are all
sitting there and sort of bumper to
bumper and for me is just once
and so I I said well yeah I had no
choice I really had to do this there's
no other way
so I rationalize it but I then think of
these other people sitting left of me
and write to me and in front of behind
me and they experience this every day
do they have they ever worked out what
this is costing them in time how much
time this is this is wasted for them
multiplied by five days a week the
cumulative I think 35 35 weeks a year so
we we don't think about it and that's
what I meant by by awareness and I think
by being deliberate is once you're aware
of the the time you spend your you can
sort of account for time more easily
then you can begin to be deliberate
about what you do for instance you
mentioned where people might be
listening to this podcast I I don't
particularly like driving
but I see driving as something a great
opportunity to listen to podcasts
sometimes listen to the radio but most
of the time I accumulate lots of
podcasts and then when I need to drive
an often drive from here to the
continent so these are long trips that
means I can listen back to back to
several episodes of freakonomics or your
podcast or of EECOM talk or you name it
I mean is there's a whole raft of things
and I tend to listen to and I think to
me that is like good management in the
way in the same way that you use your
you manage your money well good money
management this is good time management
time management is not just about dying
management it's about being aware of
where there is a sort of downtime a time
that is otherwise not very well spent
because as you as you mentioned earlier
we can't bottle up time we it just goes
by and so we all use it or we lose it
and that awareness can achieve you
better to use it better there is a
concept in economics called mental
accounting I didn't already have heard
of it maybe some of your earlier be able
to comics guests may have mentioned it
but I'll quickly or briefly explain it
mental accounting is like having
multiple virtual bank accounts and you
have one account for the rent I want to
come for you for the the bills I want to
count for going out for meal and one
account for food and clothing or
whatever so you cut it up it's basically
it's all the same money because money is
as they say is fungible you a dollar is
a dollar what have you spending onyx
it's exactly the same dollar but by
dividing it up into virtual pots or
accounts you can manage it better you
can have a savings account where you
saved up for Christmas for holiday and
basically it's there it's got its
earmark there's a label on it and it
means that you're not really supposed to
take money out of that's for something
else and there is there's an
dudes I think it's I forgets one of them
is dustin hoffman's off Minh and the
other one is I forget two actors who
used to live together in Hollywood when
they were young and in bikinis and and
one of them goes back home in and wants
to borrow some money because they've run
out of money to food or something and
they actually literally have jars on the
kitchen counter and there is money for
something else in another jar but they
are unwilling to take the money from
that jar to pay for whatever is they
need to pay so that's a mental
accounting and we can do the same thing
with our own time we can dedicate time
to a certain activity and not used it
for something else all too often we
begin a task and we just carry on and we
we keep on it's like throwing good money
after bad because it may not be the best
use of our time at a particular moment
and so if we're deliberate about how are
we going to be using our time and say
right I'm going to be working on this
for this amount of time and then I'm
going to be doing something else that is
also important at that moment in time
it's that kind of deliberateness that I
was alluding to earlier on I understand
the listeners will be familiar with
Parkinson's law as well which is we work
expands to fill the time given for it
just one of the reasons that timeboxing
your tasks throughout the day is an
important way because everyone will be
familiar from when they're at school
of what if you're like me you might be
familiar of leaving your assignment
until the last minute and and handing it
in
you've actually got some students of
yours as submitting assignments ready
for midnight tonight so I guess you'll
be suffering with the 11:59 p.m.
submission deadlines and all that stuff
there are a few that have asked for an
extension well I mean method they're
just leaving it until 11:58 aren't they
and then they can ask for one but yeah I
totally understand one one of the
examples that you used in one of your
blog posts I thought
hilarious and fascinating can we talk
about the Estonian police speeding fines
please oh yes yes that's a fantastic
idea I think the Estonian police in a
few months ago I think tried out on a
particular piece of roads an alternative
way of penalizing people who were
speeding in most countries when you get
caught speeding you get a ticket and in
some situations the fight can be quite
extensive depending on by how much you
exceed the speed limits but here in
Finland they come they came up with a
different idea and so they stopped
people speeding and they gave him a
choice between paying I think for for a
sort of an average excessive speed the
fight would be something like fallen
euro so just like a good 3 min 50 pounds
or they could wait for an hour just stay
there for an hour and then they could be
they could go get didn't have to play
anything but they just had to wait by
the roadside for an hour about half of
the the people they stopped opted to
wait about half didn't so you can
imagine from that how much these people
value their time because effectively
they paid fallen euros for an hour I
don't think even I think there are very
few people who get paid that amount of
money so stopping by and saving from the
burns for some people that was that was
not enough so to speak so they they they
went off but the others did stay now I
sort of used or not a little bit because
I think if you look at some of some
common behavioral economics principles
one of them which comes from an acronym
that was put forward by the people at
the behavioural insights team in UK that
the former nudge units and they have a
simple very clear framework for behavior
interventions going by the name of East
acronym stands for easy attractive
social and timely so any intervention
should score highly of those four things
should make life easy
it should be appealing so people who
would want to do it should be social
other people do should be timely than
intervention that is done at the moment
that it it mutters has more effect on an
intervention that is happening at some
unrelated time when you think about it
when you get find well these are work so
you drive along you get flashed again
seen a flash in your rear unless I've
been called okay so you forget about is
for you who drive more slowly for a for
a little while and then you forget about
it and then a fortnight later the the
the you get the notes that you got
caught and you got a little sort of
payment slip there you need to pay what
other pounds are some things aren't
pants but the connection between the
behavior that incurred the fine and
defined itself is really very very loose
at that point it's such a long time ago
that you will you don't make the
connection so in this particular case
with the finished police the connection
is immediate these people most the
design will have been speeding because
they were late today they left late this
is another another aspect of poor time
management it's leaving things to mate
so they tried to make up for lost time
by speeding and get through at the
destination on time and then they get
stopped and have to wait for an hour so
all the benefits they would have had is
gone so they made the effort to try and
get there in time by breaking the speed
limit and yet they don't get there on
time so this is a kind of reinforcing
mechanism applied at the right time that
might I didn't know there was they
didn't really properly research it but I
think this is one of the things that I
would I would like to see researched
more to see whether the effectiveness in
terms of recurring speeding of this kind
of penalty would be superior to the
conventional a penalty of just basically
finding people it makes me think about
when when people buy things on a credit
card as well or when people use
contactless there was a there was a
study I think Rory Sutherland cites it
people walking out of a supermarket and
they're being asked how much do you
think you're receiving worth
and the people that paid cash were
within a you know 10% 15% people that
paid chip-and-pin
was sort of within 30 and people that
paid contactless like there might as
well have just guessed they might as
well have yes what the person next to
them receipt was and it's that
detachment isn't it it's not only the
timely detachment but also the
detachment from something that's
sufficiently visceral in our sensations
to actually make us feel like we were we
were experiencing what is happening
absolutely and I think because at the
point people are being called speeding
time is very important to them otherwise
they probably wouldn't be speeding so at
that time being delayed even further is
extra painful and is therefore more
likely to have an effect than something
that happens two weeks later when
they're forgotten perhaps even where
they were when they they got caught so
so yeah I think I think that's a it's an
interesting experiment that I think
merits further investigations in the
speech I agree you also had to look at
the relative judgments throw people who
were offering to do charity work hmm
about whether or not they were going to
spend money to contribute to a
particular cause or whether they were
going to spend their time and this gets
on to a point as well that I'd love to
move on to which is talking about
outsourcing tasks to other people based
on your own value for your time so let's
let's get into that can you tell us
about that study yeah yes yes that's
that's interesting study I forget who
was done by it's somebody at University
of Cardiff and they looked at what how
people value people donating to charity
and depending on whether they volunteer
or whether they donate money and they
normalized it so that they the value of
the donation was similar to the value of
a week's work so to speak so it was
entirely equivalent and what they found
is that in the eyes in the eyes of
others the donation of time was seen as
much more valuable the seventy percent
wasn't
yes yes yeah so that's that's
interesting in itself so whereas the if
you take the old time is money
equivalents that is clearly not true
because people feel that people who
volunteer and then at that time are more
praiseworthy than than people who simply
dip in their pocket and give some money
why do you think that interesting um
well I
I can I can theorize and my theory is
that we we all experience time in a much
more similar way than we experience
money money our experience to money is
very much dependent on our point of
reference and therefore how wealthy we
are so to an economist dollar is a
dollar but to somebody who's a
millionaire dollar will be worth less
than to homeless person who has no money
at all but the time time is much more
equal for for multiple people and so we
are it's easier for us to put ourselves
in a position of somebody who gives up a
whole week of their time or their
personal time to do something for
somebody else than for somebody to give
up on a thousand dollars yeah I wonder
how much of that as well as effortful
signaling about the fact that I know I
can tell you people who have donated
chunks of money yeah to to charity but I
don't know many people that have donated
a week yes exactly
well that is because we only have 52
weeks in the year we have basically
there is no limit to the amount of money
we can have now of course we we will not
give give away half our wealth either
very few people do that I mean that's
that's unless you filled out the
equation but generally the amount of
money we give is relatively modest
compared to our total wealth even though
it may in absolute figures be quite
substantial it's it's really something
that will make a difference to our
lifestyle
very few people donate amounts that make
a difference
to how they will live their life after
they've made the donation but we all
have live into limited time so we can we
find it much easier to imagine what it's
like to give up our week we have limited
amount of holidays and there's a four or
five weeks of holiday year so that's 20
or 25 percent of your holiday time
you're giving up to do something for
somebody else
let me help guys that's quite
significant now there is definitely the
likelihood that some of that is
signaling with donations of money we can
we can donate anonymously and some
people - not many the the proportion of
anonymous donations is very very small
so people really want others to be able
to see that they they gave a certain
amount of money because it gives them a
warm feeling but it also gives them a
bit of status in the eyes of others but
it can't donate time anonymously so
there that is it's pretty obvious that
you're donating the time and so this is
something where you can even if you're a
modest kind of person you can still say
it's a look see what I what I did here
yeah just going back to the study what's
interesting is that even if the
participants to the study were told that
if they had given money to this charity
the charity could have bought much more
time with that money from local people
than the one week that they were giving
up and they and the equivalent amount of
the money they gave up all the time and
still third party with other people
viewed the donation of time has more
praise worthy than the donation of money
so the utility of giving time may be
less but the status it gets you is still
more and so so time and I think there
are some interesting implications to
them both in our private lives and at
work I think I think we should be more
aware and make other people aware or the
value of our time at work so when we
when people come in and ask for our time
or when when we go and ask somebody else
for some of that time we should be more
appreciated appreciative of that time
and understand that this is a precious
scarce resource they are making
available to us and so likewise in the
other way around and it's the same thing
at home we don't we sometimes treat the
time of other people as if it's as if it
has no value will you just go and do
this can you just go to the post office
all this over and okay what's the
opportunity costs for the person
concerned is that the best they could be
doing with the time I mean it's 20
minutes walk either way to the post
office and I could be doing something
else so why are you asking me this
because you forgot yesterday to go to
the post office so it's very easy for
you to forget if you can then ask me
today to go to the post office so I
think again more awareness of the value
of time can lead to not lit not not only
a better use of time but also better
relationship because if I come to waste
your time if for whatever reason I have
some power over you and I can I can
instruct you to go to the post office
for me because I forgot to post the
letter or to send this package off
yesterday
then be a resentment you will think well
bloody how I could be doing a bit of
something interesting something nice
something useful for me but now I need
to go to the post office and waste 25
minutes half an hour so to you to make
up for some something you forgot to do
yesterday isn't interesting that with
that you we've identified that as being
something that people might be quite
cognizant of a home you know if you were
at work in a job and your boss said hey
I forgot to take I forgot to do this to
take this to the post office do you
fancy going you might actually think off
get in I got 40 minutes off work I get
to go and have a I get to go and have a
walk despite the fact that your time at
work could also be spent doing something
true but as I said in beginning one of
the one of the things that we tend to do
when we're at work is we we treated a
in a sense we've sold our time to our
boss already so if our boss wants to use
that time because it's his or her time
now so if they think that time is best
been by me by sending me to the post
office who cares um I might be either
way I suppose this is exactly where it's
literally the tip of the spear of where
the inefficiencies in wasting time come
from within a business don't they that
people are like it's 8 o'clock I'm here
it's 5 o'clock I'm gone you know
whatever we do during that time and it
takes a very it either takes a very
particular type of mindset or a special
sort of remuneration package for people
to start to bring that in because you
are right some people hate meetings they
don't want to spend their Titan eval
rather Kant famously he doesn't do
meetings I don't do meetings and you're
like well you know there's a lot of
businesses he's on the board of all of
these that angel investment companies
and stuff how do you not do meetings and
that's because that is how much he
values not only his time at the time of
everyone that's around him others other
companies that I know that their meeting
rooms are desk Alice and seedless so
they are simply a room in which
everybody can stand and it just totally
reduces it down it increases the
effortful friction of someone wanting to
call a meeting it's out okay cool you
can call them me but everyone's everyone
gotta stand and everyone's got to hold
their laptop like a like a waiter in
front of them while they're here true so
I mean is is so interested especially
for me as someone who's never worked in
a typical salaried job that's never been
my industry I've always worked for
myself but I know that that's not
typical and you know I really do hope
that some of the people that are
listening can start to if you are in a
more typical sort of salary job you can
start to assess your time while you are
at work and think well hang on
where can I make my experience either
more productive or more enjoyable for
for me or whatever it might be well yes
yeah absolutely and I think your
perrilyn is quite quite interesting I
think if you're self-employed then you
are you're really the owner of both your
money and your time and you will treat
them with more respect I think not the
time that you spend at work because
you've already sold it it's not yours
anymore I think the comparison is with
imagine that you're you go on a business
trip and you get some cash from work you
get no hundred fifty pounds to spend on
a hotel in a meal or whatever will you
be worried about how much you spend
probably not
you can't keep anything so you can't
keep the balance you have to give back
you have to a receipt for a certain
amount and a bounce you need to give
back but you can spend up two hundred
fifty pounds so you're not going to be
too concerned about how you spend that
money well I think it's very much the
same
with the time you spend at work it's
you've given it to your employer so if
if if for whatever reason you need to go
and sit in meetings five hours in a day
that's what you're going to be doing now
of course it's not true for everybody
not to one other percent of the time but
too much of the time we will really
treat that time as if it's it has no
particular value to us we just do
whatever whatever comes along and we we
don't we not deliberate enough with it I
understand I think that's such a
brilliant example the people that you
know do have a company card the
listening will know that it if he 150
pounds to spend at 249 pounds 50 pence
that goes on the snake and you've bought
a milkshake that you don't even want to
have and this that and the other I think
you're right there's there's something
probably a little bit more worrying or a
little bit more sort of malicious going
on it feels to me a lot when I speak to
people some people who have these sorts
of roles there's almost an adversarial
relationship between the employer and
the employee or the employee and the
employer that it's like they will drag
their feet slash spend the money slash
do whatever they can as much as possible
sometimes especially in
perhaps that you might be not too
enamored by and you know I I don't
really know either from an employer or
an employee's standpoint if there's not
a passion to sort of make the most of
every minute as Ben Bergeron would say I
don't know what the solution would be
for that I don't know yeah yeah I think
I think it's it's it's not normally
malice I think it's just no appreciation
for something that has no value I mean
even in in social policy there is a case
can be made for making people pay for
much of the services they get because
once you pay for something you you
actually value to it and you start
caring for it more so I'm not even
remotely suggesting that at work we
should pay our colleagues for their time
although as a principal it's probably
not bad and I think there have been
experiments even at Google where there
were sort of there was a virtual Google
dollar being used that you could use to
to buy colleagues time but I think
another concept that I use in my work as
well is the economics concept of
externalities where this is where
transaction between two parties involves
a third party or actually doesn't
involve them but the third party bears
the consequences of it well so I mean a
good example of externalities in society
is pollution so you take plastic
pollution for instance and the plastic
that is now filling up our rivers and
oceans so you go down to Tesco's or
Sainsbury's and you get some plastic
bags because you can't be bothered to
take your own bags you get added full of
free bags you get home you you unload
them and then you just throw them away
and they blow out of your waste biddin
on the outside and they blow into the
local river and they find their way to
the sea so the scenes are being polluted
whereas the transaction was just between
you and Sainsbury's you got some some
free bags and so somebody else is
suffering the consequences likewise
polluting industries that pollute the
air or the water and so on the same can
happen within organizations where I mean
to give you an example where finance
tells procurement you need to squeeze
down our suppliers we want to pay less
because we have price erosion we need to
compensate for that so we're gonna pay
less for our raw materials next year and
this year so they go negotiate and they
get a better price what they don't
realize is that the supplier is saying
right ok if we are getting less money
for our product we're not going to give
as much support anymore so if if there
is a problem with our our supplies
during a sub we're not going to be on
their doorstep within half an hour we
might give them some telephone support
but obviously it's not part of the it's
not part of the official written
contract it was part of the unwritten
total agreement and so the people
somewhere else in the organization who
need the help of the supplier will
suddenly find that they don't get the
help anymore so that's an externality
the finance and procurement were happy
because Finance said you must shade 5%
of the bill of materials and procurement
sharing of 6% essentially we did really
well and then somebody else is suffering
the concept operations and logistics
have worked yeah yes those kind of
things precisely so but I think there is
so many situations at work where what we
do on our own or we do with another
colleague effects third parties and we
don't know in what way and it may well
make it may well waste their time but if
we don't know will happily waste the
time because we don't pay for it we it's
not even visible so that's why I again I
keep on hammering on this notion of
awareness we need to be aware of the
consequences of what we do on other
people including of their time and it
may not it may I mean we could do it
this way or that way doesn't make much
difference to us but if we did this way
it's gonna waste somebody's time and
maybe half an hour half a day if we do
it that way it won't waste any time at
all but if we don't know we can't do the
right thing and this is because
within an organization you don't have a
market mechanism to show the expense of
something that is a specific book to a
colleague if you see what I mean
absolutely so I've got I've got a
question I want to finish on but before
I get into that is there anything else
do you want to bookend the discussion on
time or are you happy with everything
we've covered so far well I think maybe
one final thing that I wrote about it
recently is its deadlines the the use of
deadlines and particularly self-imposed
deadlines we we sometimes set deadlines
we yeah I mean we must get this done by
then and it can be a very good mechanism
for making the limited amount of time we
have salient and we have a countdown
clock mentally or we can have a real
clock and so we okay this much time left
we can plan if we know that we as we get
closer we really need to get it done
whether it's at work or whether it's at
home we can do this but we should be
careful not to be too dogmatic about
using deadlines like this because
there's always a trade-off to be made
and so sometimes time not spent but
because a deadline is basically saying
no phone time spends beyond this moment
in time
and if you if you don't go beyond that
then presumably there is some kind of
value or finishing whatever you have by
then I mean you you you give the example
of my students and their final
assignment for this this course so they
need to submit it by midnight tonight
it's midnight central time so they've
got another another 11 hours I got a
little way to go but so some of them
have asked for an extension and they got
it because there were in time and if
they ask for one now then they won't get
it it will get penalized and but so they
need to think about should I submit my
assignment on time and meet the deadline
or should I submit it late get a penalty
but have a better assignment mm-hmm and
I think that's the kind of trade-off
that we don't always make we can become
obsessed by a deadline and
and not really work out what the true
cost would be of exceeding a deadline or
meeting the deadline as well as set set
a self-imposed deadline which forces you
to make a suboptimal decision one that
potentially given only a small increase
of the deadline would have increased the
quality of the decision by a significant
margin correct correct and I think I
mean to give you another sort of
practical example you need to catch your
train and it's really quite important
you get my train but how important is it
are you are you going to be leaving the
house without checking that you actually
close the windows and doors because I
really need to get the train or are you
gonna say well I'd rather check the
house and I'll take the next train okay
there's going to be some costs involved
with that but at least I know my house
will be secure and the iron will be
unplugged and eleventh sort of switch on
the gas stove and everything so my house
is not burning down so when he when he
put it so extreme then clearly nobody is
going to say I'm gonna rush out of the
house leave windows and doors open and
the iron on the ironing board because I
need to catch my train nobody's going to
do that but if it's not that extreme we
don't always think about it about what
it is we would gain by catching the
train and meeting our deadline or what
we would lose by not meeting that
deadline but what we'd gain in terms of
the benefit of our house being secured
on the equivalent so I think deadlines
can be can be useful but we should be
careful not to treat them as something
that then begins the dictator's I think
we need to be willing to look at
compromising either way and what the
cost and the benefit of going on the
side would be it's interesting that I
love thinking about where the rubber
meets the road with these sorts of
discussions exactly what would would you
be prepared to have one window half open
would you be prepared to have one window
yeah fully open but it's an upstairs
window or would you be acted at it like
so we do we always do this and it's
ruined we used to have a big section on
the propane fitness podcast which I was
Gaston before I started this one and we
have a big section called would you
rather and it was would you rather
submitted by listeners and there would
always be something which had a value
that was negotiable and we would find a
value that someone would accept and then
the ruin it completely ruined this
segment we got rid of it because we just
kept playing the same game which was we
would pick the value someone would
accept and then take it down by unit and
then take it down by unit and then take
it down but it was also you did for 50
grand okay so would you do it for $49.99
would you do it for 4 now and you just
go ah well like II just I don't know I
don't know exactly where but where the
rubber meets the road did those sorts of
discussions I think is it's really
really interesting and you spoke about I
tell you what before I ask the question
I've been really excited to ask you you
mentioned that one of the ways that
people can insulate / protect themselves
from this is through planning can you
just can you just explain how you think
planning sort of ties into the deadlines
and sacrifice sort of well I think yeah
yes yes I can I think I read planning
some what I mean firstly I'd say I'm not
the person who got that I mean sometimes
when I work with people I see they open
their outlook diary and it's got all
these nice colored boxes I don't have
that many boxes but I do it I didn't
mentally in in a sense I think about
what I need to do I think about when I'm
roughly going to be doing it to me it's
about this awareness and being
deliberate about the time so for me that
is planning and I I think what's
important also is what is my purpose if
I'm if I'm going to finish my blog post
for Friday then that's what going to be
my main focus but it doesn't mean that
I'm going to be doing this until
midnight and drop know this is where the
mental accounting comes in I'm aware
that I need to take a break I'm going to
have a cup of tea I'm gonna maybe watch
something on television and then I'll
carry I'm working on it so it's it
really is I think it's probably a
parallel with mindfulness as well
a time mindfulness that is a volunteer
being conscious of time being conscious
the fact that it's valuable and that you
need to use it well but also that you
I mean interestingly I just tweeted a
story earlier today about the value of
doing nothing so I actually I sometimes
literally do nothing and I I think it's
very valuable doing nothing so there is
I don't look at my phone don't look at
anything don't even think about anything
just basically floats can be very useful
and so making time for that is the case
of being aware of the need and being
deliberate about creating that time it's
not necessarily I'm going to be doing
nothing between 1144 and 12:05 tomorrow
lunchtime but it's about being basically
a being in control of of your time to me
that is what what planning is if if you
needs your diary to do that then fine
but you don't necessarily need a diary
it's the sense of being control of what
you do when yeah the tool doesn't really
matter but the deliberateness does it's
I can't remember I read the quote
earlier on today so I'm kicking myself
for not being able to remember it but
many of the problems of man
are due to the fact that you can't sit
alone with himself in a room for half an
hour yes and you know it sounds like you
are also interestingly if my meditation
coach Bryan is listening he will know
that my particular pathway of meditation
at the moment is do-nothing meditation
by Shinzon young and that specifically
for anybody that's interested is what he
calls completely taking the hands off
the wheel and it is the practice of no
practice so my meditation on the morning
doesn't even have me clearing my mind of
thoughts if thoughts arise they're
allowed to there's no fixation or
suppression but the only thing that I do
is drop an intention to control so it's
like eat that the thought about putting
my hands back on the wheel gets that's
the only thing I'm allowed to think
about thinking about and that's it which
is your
doing that like learning to let go of
controlling thoughts even in a
meditative practice is because meditate
meditation in itself in some forms
especially some of the ones that I've
been doing is still about we're bringing
the focus back to the breath we're
bringing the focus back to the somatic
sensations in the body or the self-talk
or the my the mental imagery or whatever
it might be and yeah the the power of
literally doing nothing is is an
interesting one I think it was really
really good to go through that but I
have a final question for you which I
asked Richard chaton I'm gonna ask you
the same thing as well so you're
stranded on a desert island stranded on
a desert island on your own and you're
only allowed to have three mental models
with you can take three mental models on
to the island with you so they can be
either the most novel or the most
interesting there can be a bias
heuristic whatever it is that you you
want we go to choose three and you got
to take them with you
which three you're gonna choose I'm
gonna be on my own there yep mmm well
I'll tell you what you can you can
imagine that there might be other people
there as well because that will probably
broaden the broaden it but you got to
choose three you got to choose a
favorite three quite sure what you mean
by mental there's any any any any bias
any heuristic so you could have some
cost fallacy opportunity cost you could
have the pratfall effect you could have
anchoring you could have self-serving
bias well I think one thing I would
definitely take with me is cost-benefit
analysis okay that's the the it's it's
the way you make deliberate decisions so
considering what the the costs and
benefits are of the the multiple options
that are in front of you I think that
would serve me well even if I'm totally
on my own on a desert island I think
what I would also take is
optimism bias because I think life can
get a bit depressing if you're not
optimistic optimism might be well god
knows maybe it [ __ ] might appear on our
eyes and then take me away from this
island or I might discover important
things that helped me make my life more
comfortable on the island what would be
the third one would serve me well well
maybe I don't know whether you'd treat
as a as a mental model but I would take
mindfulness I I find even when I'm
driving occasionally and it's it's it's
probably the rice out of doing nothing
but just sort of taking in the sight
taking in the landscape taking in the
way the trees look maybe there's a bit
of frost on the trees and and being
really conscious of that I think that's
also something that would serve me well
on on a desert island that is the
ability to experience my environment to
the full might being mine from that way
even if I have nothing else if I have
not any any of my accoutrements that
make my life interesting and pleasant
these days if I could be mindful in
whatever the nature would be in my
there's an island I think that would
certainly well I think it would stop you
from getting bored as well the
resolution that you're looking at some
you know if you're on this small desert
island you've seen the same trees every
day you need to be able to look at them
with with optimism you need to be able
to to be able to see them freshly
there's a couple of them a couple of
mental models that that come to mind saw
George McGill who I did a mental models
podcast with this hanlin's razor and
Occam's razor and he made he made
Miguel's razor and Miguel's razor was
when offered two choices choose the one
which suggests which offers the most
look or adventure and that actually
interestingly the looker adventure side
might be how you ended up on the desert
Island you might have thought I'm gonna
take I mean this this sounds like a
great adventure and now you shipwrecked
and there is stranded on a desert island
yeah well the question is will it take
you off the island again yeah exactly a
lucky create get get Wilson the
volleyball on there strapped symbaloo
shoots to it to a raft Cohen today's
been fantastic thank you so much for
coming on if the listeners want to find
out more if they want to see some of
your work where should they head well I
should I should probably head to my
medium site I mean I published both
WordPress thereby addresses who sees
I'll spill that it's kom as in my first
name
fuchsias as in my illustris ancestor and
Confucians net or on medium I'm medium /
at Confucius on medium can always follow
me on Twitter as well
I'm a prolific Twitter tweets not not
least my own stories but also other
interesting stuff to do with human
behavior that I discovered on the Nets
left Writing Center I can agree more
massive massive appreciation for you for
coming on and you're publishing your
publishing weekly at the moment on every
week that's that's a serious schedule
the piece every week yes that's right
and I try to stick to it to the point
I'm actually I publish in in English and
Dutch as well so it's published on a
Dutch Belgian Dutch language news
website so I translate it usually in the
30 hours of Friday morning - yeah I know
I know that I know that feeling of
completing my show notes a couple of
hours there's been a few a few
interesting times because of the
publishing the time that these episodes
go live is 6:00 a.m. in the UK and
there's been a couple of times where
I've been away in Bali which is 13 hours
ahead or I've been in Boston which is 8
hours like 6 hours behind and I'm
thinking like this [ __ ] like I've got
half an hour to get this episode up
because I it's actually 8 only 1 a.m.
here but it's 6 a.m. at home and blah
blah well so for me even though it's a
self-imposed deadline because nobody
tells me to to publish by 10 o'clock on
a Friday morning yeah but it helps I
totally convinced if I didn't set myself
that deadline I would long have given up
posting a post every week and not
discipline I think it's a very good
discipline to think as well I mean
writing is the best way to learn to
think better I couldn't agree more and I
think is well the what we've both got is
a level of accountability you know there
will be people that waiting for your
blog post and if the blog post doesn't
go up maybe no one will actually say
something but you know they'll probably
think it'll be a high in a second was
Coons article from today and that's the
social social fear that social pressure
it's enough of a motivation to keep us
both going each week I suppose it is
even if it's totally imagined nobody's
really thank you so much for your time
right everything that we think today
will be linked in the show notes below
including the medium page for yourself
and your Twitter you know what to do if
you enjoyed this episode feel free to
comment below like share and subscribe I
would really appreciate it but for now
Koon thank you so much Chris
thanks very much it's been a very very
enjoyable thank you
[Music]
you